ああ
こちらネタネタ超会議
炎上ブースからお届けしております
本日はお集まりいただきありがとうございます
youtuber
はじめしゃちょーの助手の棚澤と
野手だ
今日の議題なのですが、せっかくファンの皆様に
お集まりいただいたので直接みなさんの意見も
いただきたく
参考までにみなさんに動画のネタを考えていただきたく
思っております
しかし、動画作りで
難しくなるのは炎上
のリスクでございます。youtubeに動画を配信する際
一番注意すべき点としてはその動画を
配信することによってユーザーに悪影響を
及ぼさないか
真似すると危険ではないかなどの危険性を
留意したうえでネタを考えなければなりません
そこで今回は炎上について研究をしている
プロフェッショナルの方をお招きしています
有中場（youtuber）
大学 炎上学部教授の円譲教授です。どうぞ
～拍手～
えー、皆様円譲教授はこれまで50年間
炎上についての研究に取り組んでおりまして
未だ謎が多い炎上のアルゴリズムと
法則についての研究分野における先駆者と言われております。
先日発売された
円教授の著作本enjoy!炎上は
全国20部の売り上げを出しております。是非全国の
書店でお買い求めください
それでは教授自己紹介をよろしくおねがいします
円譲です
えー。まぁyoutubeの世界ね
炎上というものが非常にあるので
まぁ今回
はじめしゃちょーだっけ　　　　　　　あ、はい
あのー、その人のネタをちょっと考えてもらってね、
まぁその、いろんなネタがあると思うんだけども、
炎上の
怖さをね
まぁ
はい。
それではみなさんに早速ネタを考えて
いただきます。例えば水を2秒で3リットル
飲んでみた、教授、こんな内容のネタはどうでしょうか。
いやぁ、炎上しますね。
あのー、水というものはやはり
早飲みすれば、危ないというか
体内に一定量の水分を、
こうオーバーしてしまうと、
人はその、、致死量になってしまうので、
危ないので
まあそれはやめておいた方が
良いと思いますね。
なるほど。
思い浮かんだネタがある方は、
挙手して頂けますでしょうか。
・・・
じゃネタの方、お願いします。
『生ハムを、何枚重ねたら、
自分の身長の、高さになるか』っていう
企画
どうですか。
なるほど。
とても、素晴らしいネタだと思うのですが。
円教授。
いや、たぶん炎上しますね。
生ハムは、
手で重ねるんですか？
ピンセットで
ピンセットかぁ～
ま、でも仮にもしピンセットに
あのばい菌がついているとぉ、
ひょっとするとばい菌を取り込んでしまう。可能性が
あって
ま、病気になってしまうかもしれませんよねぇ
それを子供がまねしてピンセットで…
（ｗｗｗ）
子供がまねしてピンセットで生ハムを重ねて
自分の身長までしようとすると
あのー
まねした子供までも
そのピンセッのトばい菌で
病気になってしまうので、
すぅぅ（息を吸う）
ちょっとやめた方ｇ…
やめといた方がいいかなぁー
や、でも面白いね。
いいと思いますありがとうございます。
ありがとうございました。
続いて、ほかに、ネタがある方
『童謡「どんぐりころころ」を完全再現してみた』
ああ＾～
『童謡「どんぐりころころ」これを完全再現、してみた』
これも～まあ
炎上しますね～
どんぐりが
池にはまる
だけでもダメなんですか
まあ池にもし
s、魚がいるとしましょう。
そうするとぉ
どんぐりころころしてきたどんぐり
を、餌と勘違いしてしまって
食べてしまう。
そうなると
そのお魚さんにとっては致命傷になりかねない。
そこでまた一つの命が
失われてしまうのでちょっと
すぅぅ（息を吸う）
避けていただきたい、ところではありますねぇ。
なるほど。
ありがとうございました。
次のネタ、がある方は
では
二列目の
・・・
ウエッホォッ！！
エホッエホッエホ
エホ
国語辞典を一言一…
一言一句漏らさず朗読してみた
ププッ
『国語辞典を一言一句漏らさず朗読してみた』
こちらも炎上するんですか、教授。
すぅぅ（息を吸う）
これは炎上しますね。
あの～国語辞典、文量が多いので
もしこれが、Youtubeを見ている子供たちが
国語辞典を全部音読、朗読するのを
まねしてしまうと
あの
子供たちの寝る時間が確保できなくて
子供たちの、あの成長に悪影響を及ぼしてしまうので、
すぅぅ（息を吸う）
これはちょっと
やめといた方が
いいかもしれないですねぇ～
保護者から
怒られるということですか。
う～ん
ありがとうございました。
次のネタがある方は
『食パンをくわえながら角を
全力でまがったら、どのくらいの確率で
人と、ぶつかるか検証してみた』
ぁぁ～なるほどぉ（小声）
クスクス…
ありがとうございます、
『食パンをくわえながら、角を
全力で
まっ、がったらどれ位の確率で
人とぶつかるか』ありがとうございます。
これは、はじｍ…
教授
（ｗｗｗ）
…どう、お考えでしょうか。
いやぁ、これは炎上しますねぇ
あのぉ、まあ
二点、挙げられるんですけどぉも、
その、くわえてるパンの落下による、あのパンが
汚れてしまって
そのパンを仮に
あのぉぉ、スタッフが後ほどおいしくいただきました、
といったとしても
ま、ばい菌が乗っている可能性があって
ま、そういう病気になってしまう可能性が
という危険性と、
角を曲がったときに
ぶつかっていた方との
接触事故による
ま、死亡事故の可能性も少なからずあるので
ま、そちらもちょっと、炎上しかねないかも
しれないですねぇぇぇぇぇ
アニメで我慢しましょう。
ありがとうございました。
次のネタが
がある方はお願いします。
『センター試験受けてみた』
ありがとうございます。『センター試験受けてみた』
こちらの動画はどう思いますか。
すぅぅ（息を吸う）
これも炎上しますねぇ
センター試験、受けてみた
やはりぃ、子供の見ている方が多いので
もし、子供たちが
『センター試験受けたい、受けたい！』
ってなってしまうと
センター試験当日、
各地の会場に
あの小学生が
あふれだすかもしれない
で、受験もできないのに来てしまうと
えー
受験の妨害になってしまって
これまた社会問題になりかねない
非常に危険なネタっｗｗ
（ｗｗｗ）
になっております。
これはちょっとやめといた方がいいかもしれないですねぇ。
ありがとうございました。
次のネタがある方は
『ポケモンGOのアプリの、アカウントを
消してみた』
『ポケモンGO のアプリのアカウントを
（ｗｗｗ）
こちらどうでしょうか。
これはちなみに誰のアカウントを？
はじめしゃちょーさんの
ああ、自身で自分のアカウントをけす。
こりゃ一体
どうしてまたそのようなことを
（ｗｗｗ）
そうですね、これがもし
誰かがはじめしゃちょーの
ポケモンGOの
アカウントを
消す、みたいになると、そのひとにこう
火の粉が
かかって
炎上じゃないですけども
自分自身で自分のアカウントを
消すとなると
ま、炎上しなさそうに
一見見えるんですけども
ま、消されたポケモンの気持ちを
考えてみて下さい。
『六本木ヒルズでバンジージャンプ
してみた』
ププッｗｗ
『六本木ヒルズでバンジージャンプしてみた』
（ｗｗｗ）
こちらの動画は、
どうでしょうか。
あの以前本人から
聞いたんですけどもぉ
六本木ヒルズの屋上から
プリン、落としてキャッチ
してみたいと
いう話を
えぇ、UUUMの方に
してみたんですけども
「屋上系は…どうしてもやめてくれ」と
いう声がかかってしまい
ちょっとやめといた方がいいかも
しれないですｗ
『24時間勉強し続けると
どの位頭がよくなるのか』
24時間勉強してみると
どれくらい頭がよくなるのか
こちらの動画はどうですか。
やぁこちらもひょっとしたら
炎上しますかもしれないですねぇ（？）
キッ↑ズが
もしまねして
「勉強したい、勉強したい」
「パパママ」
「24時間勉強するね！！」
ってやってしまうと
学校に行かなくなってしまいまして
不登校率の促進につながってしまいますので
こちらもちょっとリスキー
ではないですかねぇ
やめておいた方が
いいかもしれないですよ。
はい。（引き）
すぅぅ（息を吸う）　　　　　惜しいなぁ
失礼だったら、すいません。
ただのへりくつ
にしか